Yes! We just talked about Unreal Engine
5.2 a popular, game development platform
approximately a month ago, and now the new 5.3
version is already here. So what’s new here? Can
this really be improved so easily? I mean, the
previous version put up a clinic in simulating
pretty much everything we could think about.
In their demo, we could drive a virtual car
and even the tire pressure and compression
was simulated. And so much more. And now,
5.3 gives us everything that a Wise Fellow
Scholar could ask for - better explosions,
ray traced effects, better cloth
simulations, and more! Yummy!
First, now hold on to your papers Fellow Scholars,
because they now support sparse volume textures.
Oh my! Yes! This enables us to create or bring in
already existing volumetric simulations of smoke,
explosions, and more. And it also supports
OpenVDB. This is a software library that helps us
compress down the immense amount of data that is
required for these simulations. Not so long ago,
we looked at NVIDIA’s amazing NeuralVDB paper,
a variant of this that can cut down the memory
footprint of such a simulation by get this,
up to 100x. 100x less memory needed. Wow.
And now, we can not only create or import
these simulations, but we can also render
them. Oh yes, that is light transport.
Ray tracing if you will. Something that
we talk about all the time here, on Two Minute
Papers. Here, we start out with a noisy image,
and over time, it clears up, or if we don’t
have the time, we can use a noise filtering
algorithm to fill in the missing details. This
is typically for off-line applications here and
not for real-time games, but typically for
feature-length movies. But, don’t forget,
real time ray tracing is also possible, and it
might come to Unreal Engine quicker than we think.
They also have a new skeletal editor, where I
really liked that now you can also paint these
skinning weights right on the body. Okay,
but what does that mean? Skinning weights
determine the influence of joints and bones
on the body, and how the body should move and
deform around them. This can now be done much
more efficiently directly in Unreal Engine.
Cloth simulations, now are based on the XPBD
paper, extended position-based dynamics. A
legendary NVIDIA paper from 2016, it finally
made it to the industry and into the hands of
millions and millions of users. I am so happy
to see this kind of tech transfer happen,
and it really shows the world that these papers
that you hear about here are real. They get out
there in the real world and make it better. Note
that they also have an incredible AI-based cloth
simulator too that can simulate muscle movements
too. These results are truly something else. Wow.
They also introduced orthographic
rendering to Unreal Engine,
this helps us eliminate the distortion that
arises from the shape of real camera lenses
leading to a really distinctive look.
This is going to be great for not only
architectural visualization projects,
but for top-down strategy games too.
And there is so much more!
They added camera rig rails,
that makes your in-game cameras move a
little more like a real cinematic camera,
these amazing virtual LED production stages
can now run with higher resolution and
higher frame rates, wide-angle lenses,
multi-camera shoots at the same time.
Also, something that I don’t hear too many people
talking about is support for foveated rendering.
This is for those virtual reality headsets that
can track where you look, and create more detailed
geometry around that spot, and do less work on the
parts you are currently not looking at. Something
that we talked about almost 400 episodes ago, and
now, once again, it is making its way into the
hands of the whole world. Once again, to my joy,
the papers coming alive. What a time to be alive!
Lighting with volumetric fog is also better,
these beautiful multi-layer materials
are rendered better. So cool! This is
going to be a huge improvement for anyone
creating video games, animation movies,
virtual worlds, and many other creative
things. So now, let the experiments begin!
This was Two Minute Papers with Dr. Károly
Zsolnai-Fehér. Subscribe if you wish to see more.